copie toro euh vous allez à l'activateur nous
activons toro
donc le test du contrôleur manuel est sans
problème copie
merci
nous surveillons la plage de manœuvre inverse en
parlant simultanément
est légèrement
plus grande qu'un
65 mètres séparant maintenant la précellule cette
superbe vue du nouveau module de nœud  et
le mode agc de livraison de progression ci-joint
de la sonde d'amarrage avant du prashal
que vous pouvez voir dans cette vue
car il est sur le point de passer
environ 18 mètres de portée
trois degrés vers la gauche vers le bas
et les véhicules soyuz pilotés font
maintenant partie de la station spatiale internationale
vous  peut le voir là